are you looking for something to play on
your Nintendo switch well this week
brings a bounty of new games just
waiting for you to play them I'm Matt
and this GameSpot news update is ready
to jump into the cart of a tie-wearing
gorilla and race a dragon lizard thing
for new games hit the switch this week
the first of these is puyopuyo Tetris
which takes two classic puzzle series
and matches them together it's a
delightful game that I just can't get
enough of the next two are the Zelda
Lite Kimiko which features gorgeous
pixel art and the Neo Geo racing classic
over top last but not least Mario Kart 8
deluxe launches on April 28 it brings
everything from the Wii U game including
the DLC and updates it with a new and
improved battle mode that's it for this
week but if you want to keep up to date
on all of the Nintendo switch releases
then be sure to hit those like and
subscribe buttons Mario Kart 8 received
the 9 out of 10 in our review GameSpot's
cally plaguey said that even if you
don't really care about the revamped
battle mode the smallest changes in
Mario Kart 8 deluxe refine an already
great racing game you can check out the
full video review on our Channel and if
you want to see the game in action live
tune in to GameSpot's Mario Kart 8
tournament on Friday April 29th at 2
p.m. Pacific
[Music]